[Music]
so how did you get into the capital I
just walked right in January 6 really
activated you yeah what was it inside of
you that made you think I'm going to go
inside the
capital I've been on the road meeting
some of the Jan Sixers who were sent to
jail for what they did that day did you
go to the capital to assassinate my
mother
no you're rocking your maggot tattoo and
your Trump socks there we go I can see
you're taking the sing very
seriously you're the first January sixer
to walk in and take a felony charge it
was a peaceful protest it was hijacked
Johnny what if you're wrong about
everything I've been wrong before do you
feel like you were a little brainwashed
by President
Trump I feel so remorseful for what I
did that
day the left says that you're domestic
terrorists the right says you're all
just
tourists but United States government
thinks you're all
[Music]
insurrectionists